نهج الاختيالات الايرانيه تاريخ طويل قده
النظام لحوالي اربعه عقود مستهدفا
المنشقين الايرانيين والمسؤولين الاجانب
في جميع انحاء العالم نهج بات الغرب يحذر
منه بعد ان طاله نيران الاغتيالات
والصحفيين في جميع انحاء العالم بما في
ذلك في الولايات المتحده
الاستهدافي بحق مسؤولين السابقين في
الحكومه الامريكيه
ونشارين الى الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
وكندا واوروبا اضافه الى العاملين في
المنظمات الاعلاميه التي تنتقد النظام بين
عامي 2015 و2017 قتل الطيران ثلاثه
معارضين على الاقل في اوروبا الغربيه من
بينهم ناشطون عربي ايرانيه قتل برصاص امام
منزله في هاي
في عام 2018 اتهمته هولندا ايران بالتورط
في مؤامرات اغتيال ومحاولات تفجير في
اوروبا اما في عام 2019 فنفذ النظام عمليه
اختطاف الصحفي الايرانيه روح الله ذنب من
العراق ليوعد ما في ايران العام الذي بعده
كما شهيد عام 2020 عمليه اختطاف الناشط
الاحوازي حبيب اسيود من تركيا لكن لا ينجح
النظام الايراني دوما في تنفيذ مخططاته
وفقا لمصادر واشنط بورد حيث احببت وكاله
الامن الغربيه محاوله اغتيال المستشار
الامن القومي السابق جون بولتن في واشنطن
ومحاوله اختطاف الصحفيه الايرانيه
الامريكيه مسيحيه لنجاد في نيويورك اضافه
لمحاوله قتل لمواطنين بريطانيين واغتيال
الصحفي الفرنسيه
كان القاء القبض على عصابه خطف ايرانيه في
تركيا كانت تسعى لخطف احد المعارضين
للنظام رانيا
وتيره عمليات النظام الايراني ضد معارضيه
في الخارج تاتي ضمن نهجي عدم التدخل
بالاعتماد على العملاء اوكلاء لتنفيذ
العمليات بمقابل ماديا ضخم يقدموا
لمجرمينا وتجار المخدرات بعضهم لم ينفذ
الاوامر تلك نهج حسب واشنطن بوست تسبب في
فشل تلك المؤامرات الايرانيه
روان حمزه العربيه